amazon has big plans for its
breakthrough into film including a Woody
Allen show exclusively for amazon prime
subscribers the u.s. director signed a
deal this month to create his first TV
series founder jeff bezos is
multi-billion dollar turnover machine is
about much more than just books and as a
result his subscription basis shot up
but his investments are weighing on
profits still Amazon surprised with net
profits for the last quarter of 2014
only sliding to 189 million euros
another Internet giant surprising
investors was google it scored a more
than 4 billion euro win but that fell
short of the market expectations
Google's main source of income is online
advertising last year that lost momentum
the competition is getting tougher as
advertising shifts from computers to
mobile phones and Google is looking for
other ways of making money but it has
stopped sales of its much talked about
Google glass the first computerized I
we're leaving management looking for a
new strategy